Breaking news, Israel has just bombed
the British military base in Cyprus and
the UK said quote, "We can confirm that
the Shahed-like drone which targeted RAF
Akrotiri on the 2nd of March was not
launched from Iran." And you need to
know how big a deal this is. US is at
liberty, assassinate JFK JFK Kennedy,
the laughing Zionist Jews when the
9/11's happening, Charlie Kirk, you name
it, okay? You name it. The Epstein
files, these people are evil.
We are teaching people how to pray. And
every time they pray, you get the share
in that reward. And when they teach
their children and their children's
children
the reward continues. Every Fajr Zuhr
Asr
>> Maghrib Isha Tarawih Tahajud [music]
Every recitation you share in the
reward. For just £100 you can help teach
20 to 60 people.
>> Like me. Learn how to pray salah. Donate
today. Donate today. Donate today.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh brothers and sisters and their
friends. Hope you guys are well,
inshallah. So, we're going to get
straight into this video, inshallah. The
US the UK airbase was attacked in
Cyprus. And they have now confirmed that
the attack or the drone that was sent
there is not that drone of Iran or it
was not flown from Iran. So, I wonder
who it could be. Which allies usually
attacks its own allies? Um let's see,
inshallah. We're going to be watching
this video, inshallah, of what actually
happened and we're going to give you a
history lesson of Israel's involvement
in so many other countries' false flag
attacks. And we know the USS Liberty
where they attacked their own American
ship, tried to sink it and kill everyone
on board so nobody can talk about it.
But here is what's happened. Breaking
news, Israel has just bombed the British
military base in Cyprus and the UK said
quote, "We can confirm that the
Shahed-like drone which targeted RAF
Akrotiri on the 2nd of March was not
launched from Iran." And you need to
know how big a deal this is. For
context, 2 days ago an Iranian drone hit
the runway at the British military base
RAF Akrotiri in Cyprus. It didn't cause
a load of damage but it hit the runway.
Now at the time we thought that was
that. However, just moments ago the UK
has released a statement saying it
actually wasn't an Iranian drone. But
something important they didn't say
whose drone it was and they didn't say
where it actually came from. And because
of that it seems like it must have been
Israel. Of course if the UK knows that
it was not an Iranian drone which hit
the base, they know where the drone came
from. So why didn't they say that? The
drone could have come from the Houthis
in Yemen. It could have come from
Hezbollah in Lebanon. But they didn't
say that. The UK just said, "Well, it
wasn't an Iranian drone." And because of
that pretty much everyone is in
unanimous agreement that it was likely
an Israeli drone that hit the British
military base as a way to try and drag
the UK into the war to support Israel
and fight Iran. Because obviously the UK
is refusing to carry out attacks against
Iran. And Israel really wants the UK
support in this war. And so Israel here
must have bombed the British military
base with a drone as a false flag to try
and drag the UK into a war for Israel
against Iran. And if we don't get a
clarification by the UK as to whose
drone this actually was, it goes without
saying it was probably Israel who bombed
the UK. So there you go. It's fun now.
So now let's go in deep having history.
And when the USS Liberty ship was
attacked, it was attacked so the
Israelis can make the Americans think
the Egyptians attacked them so they can
go harder. So now, watch the history of
the involvement. Not only that, the
Zionist Jews were known to kill other
Jews in hope and return that they would
come to their Israel great Israel plan.
And they did this in Iraq. Let's watch
inshallah. Have you ever heard this
story before? In 1949 a Zionist Jew of
German descent named Meyer Max Bennett
was sent on a mission to Iraq by the
Mossad. There he connected with another
Mossad agent, Yousef Bustani, and
planned a series of attacks on Iraqi
Jews providing him with maps,
instructions, and very specific orders
to terrorize the Jewish population. From
1950 to 1955 a wave of bombings struck
the Jewish community in Iraq. Cafes,
mechanic shops, and synagogues were all
targeted by grenades and TNT explosives.
These attacks coincided with underground
Zionist groups calling for Iraqi Jews to
leave for Israel for their safety. The
wave of false flag terrorist attacks
succeeded in forcing Iraqi Jews to
migrate to Israel. Jews had lived in
Iraq for thousands of years, but in just
two years, nearly all 130,000 Iraqi Jews
were gone. This forced the
>> All 130,000 Iraqi Jews disappeared. Why?
Because and there is even there is even
documentation of how the Zionist were
working with even Hitler
to to do to do the atrocities so they
can have a land to run to and not feel
safe because the Jews felt safe. They
lived in Muslim land for centuries,
okay? If they got any anti-Semitism, it
was either from the Crusaders or from
their fellow Jewish Zionists. That's
where it was. That's where the new
anti-Semitism comes from, not from from
us Muslims. 130,000 Jews fled to where?
Israel. Look how they orchestrated that.
Did it end there? No, cuz one of the
spies got caught, assassinated. The
other one carried on his journey doing
false flag attacks. Which country next?
Let's see for ourselves.
>> Terror attacks Yusef Bustani was
arrested by Iraqi police and later
executed. Max Bennett, the German Jewish
Mossad agent, managed to escape and
later helped organize an even larger
false flag terror attack in Egypt. In
1952, Bennett traveled to Egypt again
using his identity as a German
businessman and spent two years
recruiting agents. This time, however,
he presented himself as an innocent,
harmless businessman doing God's work by
producing equipment for the disabled.
>> Wow, what an incredibly charitable and
generous man dedicating his life to
helping the disabled. In reality, he was
setting up Operation Susanna, a false
flag operation in which Jews would plant
bombs inside Egyptian, American, and
British owned civilian targets like
cinemas, libraries, and American
educational centers. The intention was
to blame the Muslim Brotherhood and
Egyptian Communists for the attacks with
the hope that the violence would force
British troops occupying the Suez Canal
>> remain in place instead of handing over
control to Egyptian forces. Just like in
Iraq, Israel gave the go ahead for its
agents to carry out these terror
attacks. Explosions rocked Alexandria
and Cairo, but the operation fell short
of its intended scope of damage when one
of the agents flipped and informed
Egyptian authorities. Egyptian
authorities then went on to catch one
Jewish agent in the act while he was
attempting to bomb the British owned Rio
Theater in Cairo. As a result,
>> a car. Egyptian intelligence arrested
several undercover Jewish agents
including Max Bennett. When it became
clear that he would be executed for his
involvement, Bennett committed suicide.
The failed operation later became known
as the infamous Lavon Affair. Israel
denied any involvement in the Egyptian
and Iraqi false flag terror attacks, but
was later So, that's one. US is at
liberty to assassinate JFK J.F. Kennedy.
The laughing Zionist
Jews when the 9/11's happening. Charlie
Kirk, you name it. Okay, you name it.
The Epstein files, these people are
evil. These Zionist dirtbags are evil.
And now and they were doing it in Egypt,
attacking British and American places,
cinemas, libraries, etc. Where did they
go next? They went to Latin America.
Is there the Israeli connection to 9/11?
But just a month later on October 10th,
2001, two Israelis were caught with
Pakistani passports, grenades,
explosives, and guns inside the Mexican
Parliament just moments before trying to
carry out a massive terrorist attack on
Mexican officials. Their intention, of
course, was to blame it on Muslims in a
climate that was already incredibly
paranoid and fearful of Islam. The
Israeli government rushed to help impose
a media blackout on the failed plot and
pressure the Mexican government to
quietly release their Jewish agents. The
media blackout is one of the reasons why
you've never heard of this operation
before, but we know about it because
Mexican newspapers at the time covered
it in detail. And just this year, There
you go. And they do this media blackout
and they do it right now. They are
giving five year sentences to anybody
that records the damage that's Tel Aviv
receiving as we speak with Iranian
missiles that's hitting and shaking.
Some are saying that it is looking like
Gaza. Like that's how bad it is. And
they're giving five year sentences.
Okay, the only democracy in the world.
Yes, okay, they're giving that.
In Mexico, imagine with Pakistani
passports to make us Muslims be the
culprits when they are the actual evil
scum satanic worshipers themselves. And
where did they go next? Let's see. In
February of 2025, an explosion destroyed
three buses in Be'er Sheva in occupied
Palestine. Israeli authorities claimed
that two Palestinian terrorists had
carried out the attack. Zionists went
into a frenzy calling Palestinians
terrorists for attempting to kill
civilians at a time when they were
actively committing genocide in Gaza.
However, as soon as it was revealed that
it was actually two Jewish Israelis who
had planted the bombs and detonated
them, the government ordered a blackout
and all reporting on the case was shut
down. Israeli false flags don't always
have to actually There you go. There you
go. Can you imagine? They the Jew they
they themselves are killing their own
people for a propaganda.
Acting what's the definition of
terrorism? Carrying out acts of violence
for political gains. They are killing
they are the biggest anti-Semites.
Killing their own people so they can
say, "Oh, we've been persecuted." They
are the biggest anti-Semitic in this
world. And not only that, not only that
it doesn't stop there. It doesn't stop
with them carrying though. Then then
they do false false reporting. There you
go. For yourself. During Trump's first
term, thousands of bomb threats were
called into Jewish communities in the
United States and around the world.
Threats that the ADL and other groups
used as evidence that anti-Semitism was
on the rise. It later turned out however
that every single one of these threats
was made by a Jewish American Israeli
Jewish American Israeli teenager
arrested for making 2,000 anti-Semitic
bomb threats against Jewish community
centers across the US is also accused of
attempting to extort a Republican
senator who spoke out against the hoax
bomb threats. The teen went so far as to
order drugs to the senator's home while
threatening to release allegedly
incriminating photos according to a
Justice Ministry spokesperson. And he
wasn't just targeting American
institutions. 561 out of the 2,000 calls
were made to Australian Jewish community
centers and schools. Speaking of
Australia, there have been a number of
absurd false flag attacks over the last
2 years. There is very strong reason to
believe that the Zionists themselves are
responsible for these terror attacks in
an attempt to portray themselves as
victims while their beloved Jewish
colonial apartheid state commits
genocide. And there you go brothers and
sisters. Subhanallah.
The attack the drone that hit the UK
airport the UK in Cyprus.
It is not a surprise to anybody because
they are known to attack their very
close allies Americans let alone the UK.
And they will carry on doing that. And
they've been doing it. We've had rumors
of these agents these Mossad spies
agents carrying out attacks in the UAE
or even in Saudi in those regions
Subhanallah. In hope what? So it can
turn into a World War III. The moment
their existence is in jeopardy they even
have the Samson option meaning they
would nuke the entire globe. If there's
anyone that's a threat to world peace,
it is not Iran.
It is Israel. They are the ones that
would cause this harm and use nuclear
bombs, and they know that very well.
Brothers and sisters, hope you guys
enjoyed the video and were informed. Be
very informed about these things because
we can use these evidences to educate
and enlighten our neighbors who think
that Muslims are the problem, but we
know the real Satanists, these pedos who
are not only raping American girls and
getting run away to Israel, subhanallah,
and having these islands what Mossad is
using, they are even now asking to
sacrifice your American children for
their cause. And guess what? They hate
you Christians. They hate you Christians
or you Christians. Till next time,
assalamualaikum warahmatullah
wabarakatuh.
This is the new sadaqah jariyah in town.
We are teaching people how to pray. And
every time they pray, you get to share
in that reward. And when they teach
their children and their children's
children
the reward continues. Every Fajr, Dhuhr,
Asr, Maghrib, Isha Tarawih [music]
Tahajjud Every recitation, you share in
the reward. For just £100
>> you can help teach 20 to 60 people
>> like me learn how to pray salah. Donate
today. Donate today. Donate today.